but we begin this morning with breaking
news overnight at least two people were
killed when the upper floor of a
nightclub collapsed in the city of
Gwangju about 150 miles south of Seoul
South Korea cell phone video from inside
the club shows how people were literally
holding up the balcony at one point to
prevent it from falling
it's believed as many as 16 others were
injured including four American athletes
who were among those competing at the
World Swimming Championships Kenneth
Craig is here with more Kenneth good
morning well good morning to you Michele
those four American athletes who were
injured were members of the US water
polo team they were there celebrating
when the balcony collapsed without any
warning and now South Korean officials
believe that the club owners may have
been negligent chaos erupts inside a
South Korean nightclub as dozens appear
to hold up an internal balcony as it's
collapsing two South Korean men were
killed when the structure suddenly came
crashing down onto the crowd below more
than a dozen others were injured
including eight international athletes
competing in the World Aquatics
Championships in Gwangju players from
the US men's and women's water polo
teams were celebrating the Women's World
Championship victory against Spain the
day before American Kayleigh Gilchrist
of the women's water polo team suffered
a deep leg laceration and underwent
surgery at a hospital in Gwangju 3 of
her US teammates are recovering for
minor injuries FINA the international
governing body for aquatic sports says
it is monitoring the situation and
providing assistance as needed the u.s.
water polo team says all of its athletes
are safe and accounted for police have
detained two co-owners of the nightclub
and two workers who are being questioned
about whether or not the structure was
legally added to the nightclub so scary
yeah I mean you're glad it's not worse
right or sad obviously and people lives
were lost and people hurt but glad yeah
especially when you think about how many
people were inside exactly do you kind
of thank you very much